just hear me out
it's 1986 Oprah's interviewing sax
player Kenneth Gorelick known around the
world as Kenny G it's like you are
talking to and doing a few other things
with this instrument well I've never
taken any music lessons so I don't
really know exactly in 1993 he played at
Bill Clinton's inauguration by 1996 he
was starring in golf commercials my
driver used to be my least favorite Club
in the bag till I got the great Big
Bertha driver that's my favorite and his
music was the calming soundtrack of The
Weather Channel Kenny G had hit his peak
tell me that car Kenny G again but it
wasn't just any G smooth jazz the style
of music come to be the face of was
everywhere smooth jazz 94.7 smooth jazz
106.5 this is smooth jazz 106.9 how did
that happen like where the hell did
smooth jazz come from
[Music]
let's go back to Clinton's inauguration
Kenny G actually wasn't the only
saxophonist performing in fact Will
Smith the MC of one of many inaugural
events that day brought out ten sex
players to serenade the jazz loving
president this was like the who's who of
saxophonist
but it's this guy standing right next to
Kenny G where this story begins
there's no question Kenny G has one Idol
and he admits to it Grover Washington Jr
in the late 60s and early 70s Street
jazz was all but gone from pop radio the
music was becoming more experimental and
albums like Miles Davis's [ __ ] brew
established jazz fusion and eclectic
hybrid of jazz and rock is the next
iteration of the art form but some jazz
artists saw promising pop music and
began crossing over by recording
instrumental covers of huge pop hits a
shining example of that is jazz guitar
virtuoso wes montgomery's 1966 cover of
going out of my head
[Music]
yes I think I'm gonna
[Music]
that record was produced by Crede Taylor
who filled out Montgomery's mellow
guitar with strings and woodwinds
instruments that were more familiar to
pop radio listeners this song sounded
more like the Beach Boys as Pet Sounds
than it did most jazz records that came
out in 1966 and it was a smash hit
because it established a formula for
jazz that the everyday listener could
understand as this billboard article put
it the chasm between jazz and popular
music was narrowing it was through Creed
Taylor's label CTI that Grover
Washington Jr became a household name
Grover Washington defined his fourth
album with Taylor was mr. magic just
looking at the cover you know you're
gonna listen to songs that are smooth it
really is in the most simple sense and
are in the background a fairly slow
tempo on top of that is Grover saxophone
playing is simple yet infectious melody
[Music]
the second he made radio-friendly songs
he lost a lot of respect from the jazz
world and it was difficult gaining it
back here's a quote on the back cover of
his own record that reveals this tension
apparently a jazz critic went to one of
his shows and sat scowling at the bar by
the end of the show he said cat can play
just having that jazz critic admit that
he could play the saxophone was
equivalent to a bushel of five star
reviews any jazz player will give you a
list of things that they don't like
about it they don't like the lack of
technical virtuosity they don't like the
lack of harmonic interest but in my
opinion would Trump's it all is
popularity when you're dealing with art
cliques popularity is like poison if
jazz purists were quick to dismiss
Grover's mr. magic then they sure as
hell we're gonna roll their eyes at jazz
guitarist George Benson's breezin in
1976
[Music]
who's the first jazz album to ever go
platinum the title track was originally
composed by soul record producer Bobby
Womack and bears a strikingly close
resemblance to going out of my head
[Music]
George Benson is one artist that no one
could refute because he had the chops in
straight-ahead jazz and people were mad
to them he chose success over art this
downbeat magazine review of George
Benson's says it all
hearing George Benson on this album is
like watching Marlon Brando in a fairy
Stooges movie such as the relationship
between the art and the artist but then
it really mattered to the public this
masquerade the single off the record
peaked at number 10 on the Billboard Hot
100 and when the Grammy in 1977 for
record of the year
does this scat type singing you know
where he's scatting and he's playing the
thinkers are following his voice and you
couldn't say that wasn't jazz in 1976 by
the end of the 70s dozens of musicians
followed Benson and Grover's breezy
sound even taxi one of the most popular
shows to ever be on television used a
bob james pop jazz recording as their
theme song the problem well you didn't
know what to call it this reporter just
said not quite jazz but pretty stuff
inter broadcast architecture a market
research firm tasked with giving this
promising radio format a name all these
radio stations were coming on doing this
format it was like what do we call it
the way we did focus groups was a little
different we would interview people one
person at a time for 30 minutes a female
radio listener entered the room she was
saying it's jazz but it's not really
jazz and it's smooth and she goes it's
smooth jazz yeah that's what it is
it really struck a lightbulb with
everybody that was behind the glass you
know watching
on behalf of all of us at Metropolitan
broadcasting welcome to 94 7 the wave
[Music]
what you just heard was the moment one
of the first official smooth jazz
stations went on the air within a few
months KK SF in San Francisco launched W
nu a launched CD 101.9 in new york
launched it was a tipping point for the
format for sure but take a look at how
the wave marketed itself only
occasionally did they actually play what
some would consider jazz music we
started testing everything from Phil
Collins even some Hall and Oates
tunes you know vocal tracks that would
help kind of glue it all together sound
and make no mistake Kenny G was at the
center of all of it
CD 101.9 it's called silhouette and the
artist of course Kenny G love jazz Kenny
Jenkins
ladies and gentlemen Kenny G June she
was known just as much for his hair as
he was for his saxophone playing it was
the cool white boy it was just a cool
guy who plays the saxophone and I'm
gonna go ahead and say it is money he
made so much money I don't know what to
say this is I would have never expected
to win this thing yes you did Kenny
this chart shows the rise of smooth jazz
radio starting in 1987 when Katy wve
went on the air and peaked around 1997
the same year Kenny G entered the
Guinness World Records books for holding
a note for over 45 minutes sweet what
[Music]
some of smooth jazz is most attentive
fans were the at work radio listeners of
corporate America if you take the wave
to work with you and there's a fax
machine in your office shut down a few
songs that you like to hear on the wave
and and fax them to us we would get
hundreds and hundreds of faxes like
within an hour the fax machine starts
rolling smooth jazz seemed like it would
dominate forever but then everything
changed in the early 2000s Arbitron a
firm that measures audiences introduced
new technology the purple people I'm
sorry I meant to say the portable
people-meter
it's this little beeper people believed
it killed smooth jazz ppm which is still
used today is an electronic beeper that
captures audio tones masking the signal
of radio broadcasts basically it picks
up audience listenership automatically
it replaced a decade's long practice of
using paper diary entries to measure
audiences people would write down for a
week what they listened to and they
would turn it in very easy people to do
it went from that to what we want to ask
you to do is wear this on your belt all
day and we want you to do this for a
year but it often didn't work with
smooth jazz the format soft ambient
sound didn't allow for the signal to be
consistently masked in the music without
being discernible to listeners if the
signal wasn't embedded the people just
couldn't register it polling site 538
track the number of six large market
smooth jazz stations before and after
ppm in each instance they either changed
formats or shut down entirely but it
might not have been all PPM's fault I
think it's a reflection of what our
economy did our station off the air
smooth jazz radio was music for ordinary
everyday
people just trying to get through their
day stress-free it certainly never cared
about critics during its solid 20-year
run
and unlike straight-ahead jazz it didn't
care so much about challenging the
listener either and it's why from the
1960s to the 90s anything written about
the music looked like this but dig deep
into smooth jazz is history and you'll
find some really exciting music there
was an album Herbie Hancock it's called
a new standard oh man that was good but
I'd come up there talking about that I
was like oh this is what this is why I'm
doing what I'm doing or go back even
further to Grover Washington Jr as a
wine light and just listen to it as
you're cooking dinner or something
it should chill and and you know it'll
give you a feeling for why people fell
in love with this music for such a long
time
[Music]
thanks so much for watching my little
mini-series on jazz I hope to tackle so
many more stories on the genre of music
and future earworm episodes until then
I've got a great gift for you which is a
Spotify playlist full of amazing smooth
jazz songs that will definitely make you
a convert